For the ecosystem
builders out there,
I think the way
that you guys do
things is quite novel.
Can you speak through
your process a little bit?
Like how you build it,
how you're architecting this
ecosystem moving forward?
We take definitely
a credibly neutral approach
that a lot of
other ecosystems disagree with.
Credibly neutral doesn't mean
that we give every
single team the same
amount of resources
because that doesn't make sense.
But what we do
is we double down
on the teams that
are able to show
user retention and traction
themselves because that's actually
where the resources
and the attention
will go the furthest.
But actually making it
like a level playing
ground for everyone to
get to that stage,
I would say
that's kind of like
the core thesis.